the difference seen Bitcoin and cash is
that cash is fungible at least if it's a
coin if it's a gold coin is really no
different from any other gold coin and
so one is as good as another that's not
quite the true with notes because not
some serial numbers but let's ignore
that for the time being now those other
things are fungible like ears of corn or
in the old days sheep in Roman times if
twenty sheep wandered from Marcus's farm
into Crassus as farm then the court
could simply tell Crassus to give Marcos
20 sheep back and any twenty sheep it
didn't matter but nowadays of course
sheep have got little electronic
passports clipped into the rears so if
that were to happen between two Italian
farms nowadays though Marcos could go
and get exactly the right twenty sheep
back from Crassus so here's an example
of how technology has made sheep from a
fungible asset into a trackable asset
now bitcoins the same because every
Bitcoin carries with it points us to its
entire history so you can see everybody
who's on that Bitcoin or parts of it
ever since these parts were originally
mined and so you can see further perhaps
of that Bitcoin was stolen at some time
or another or probably went through
money laundering schemes or whether they
were used in the drugs trade or I've got
various other objectionable qualities
that might cause the authorities to want
to call them in and have a close look at
them what about the money laundering
thing now how does that work at present
in England you can't get good titles of
stolen goods but until 1995 you could
because there was a law called the law
of markets or Verret so if I stole your
horse and I went and sold it in
Cambridge market between dawn and dusk
then somebody who bought it from me in
good faith would end up owning the horse
and all you could then do was to sue me
or get me hanged or sense of Virginia
now this was abolished in 1995 because
it was being abused but the the rule
survives in the law of money and banking
now if you go to a Barclays Bank ATM for
example and you get out a 20 pound Lord
then even if that 20 pound note was
stolen last year in a bank robbery
that's not your problem
that's Barclays banks problem because
you got it from a regulated financial
institution and so your title to it
written similarly if you go to John
Lewis's and you buy a toaster for 30
quid and you pay them with a 50 and
you've got a 20 pound notes in your
change then you own that 20 pound note
because there's another rule which says
that if you get something for a value in
good faith right then if so long is that
something is money you get good title to
it so the Bitcoin people have been
lobbying for at least five years to have
bitcoins to be declared money because if
Bitcoin becomes money then they think
that many of the problems are installing
bitcoins and bitcoins that were used in
the drugs trade and so on would go away
so we've been looking into this and it
turns out that it isn't quite true now
government has yet admitted that bitcoin
is money but even if a court were to
find that bitcoin is money as courts for
example phone that carbon credits can be
treated as money for some purposes then
it doesn't get the the Bitcoin criminals
off the hook and the reason for this is
that to get good titles of something
that was once stolen you have to do it
in good faith now what's the meaning of
in good faith
somebody might argue that you can't
guess a Bitcoin in good faith because
everybody knows there's so much bad
stuff goes on in Bitcoin but even if you
don't buy that argument there's another
problem which is that many people in the
Bitcoin world have set up what they call
Bitcoin mixes or even Bitcoin laundries
where the idea is that you take along
your stolen Bitcoin or the Bitcoin that
you got from selling hashish um sheep
market or whatever you put this black
Bitcoin into a pot and then other people
come along and put it in their white
bitcoins into the pot and you shake the
pot very very hard and you kind of hope
that you get ten white bitcoins out no
the law is quite clear on this that if
there's money laundering then you can't
have good faith and so if you put 1
black Bitcoin and nine white bitcoins
into a pot and you shake it then if
bitcoins are held to be money what you
get out is ten black bitcoins sorry guys
asking for bitcoins to be money was the
wrong thing to ask for
because if Bitcoin had simply remained a
commodity you know like pig iron bars or
whatever then this magic wouldn't happen
the stolen pig iron bar would stir
be a stolen pig iron bar you would put
the one black Bitcoin and the ninth
white bitcoins into a passenger to shake
them and then some unlucky sod we got
the black one owed and in that case of
course economics kicks in because then
nobody's got an incentive to take part
in a money laundering scheme now the
interesting thing about this is that if
Bitcoin become money or are treated as
money for some purposes then this is a
really mortal threat
so those cryptocurrencies which provide
built-in laundries such as Manero and z
cash now in z cash for example most of
the time it works just like Bitcoin and
there's a fully traceable blockchain of
who passed on a coin to whom but you can
if you want take your zero coin and you
can put it back in the mine and have it
remind and get out one that's nice and
shiny and new in the sense that it's
indistinguishable from all the other
coins mined in that round just the same
as if you've been recasting a gold bar
you're taking a gold bar to a crooked
foundry or a bent goldsmith and got it
turned into something that was
untraceable but the effects of this
according to the law of money and
banking is actually to poison every
single kind that comes out of that mine
and this would lead regulators to ask
themselves whether or not they should
simply instruct regulated Bitcoin
exchanges not under any circumstances to
change cash or other cryptocurrencies
into currencies such as Z cash or
mineral on the grounds that these were
designed for the purpose of money
laundering and therefore there was an
issue of obstruction of justice
thrusters or Pfeiffer was something that
programmers and communications engineers
understand very very well so we went and
wrote some software which does a five
for tens of the blockchain and so
whenever coins are stolen and put in a
transaction perhaps join with other
kinds the coins that went in first